I was going to say coming in as like a
you like someone who had a YouTube fan
base you've done such a great job of
like people well first of all you have
people who know you from that but you
also have people who just know the music
but I feel like you've kind of been the
kind of sole example I think ddg has
done a solid job I'm the female he's the
male but I feel like you did such a good
job of like I don't even think of you as
like that like there's been some
YouTubers making music and the music
sucks and then they go back to YouTube
yeah but you're like to me you're artist
first now like you're so talented and
music so high level I like to say that I
I'm not a YouTuber that turned into an
artist I've I've always been an artist
and just turned into a YouTuber and now
I'm doing what I was posting it just so
happened that like some people
discovered you on YouTube yeah that was
the I guess that was the thing cuz you
know I did American Idol um two time
well I'm going just say one cuz the
first time I didn't even make the first
round but I did American Idol and I
thought that was my way when I was 18 I
thought that was going to be my way to
you know to make it to make it how far
did you get um I think top 40 and they
booted me they were booting groups they
had to get rid of people so I you know
they were tripping yeah I my dreams were
really crushed but I was young and so
then from then I was like I'm not going
to really do music anymore maybe this
industry is not for me maybe I should
just do gospel you know I grew up
singing in church um but then I started
YouTube cuz like I mean I had a I had
got pregnant I had a son it was broke
and like YouTube was you know it was it
was there for people who don't know it's
free to like if you have a camera you
have an iPhone you could make a YouTube
channel we were doing it off iPhone yeah
and then eventually when you get that
first check you get your a camera but
like I I still say like to this day um
you know I left YouTube for a little bit
but I'm I'm going back you are uh I'm
going back well I used to do like pranks
and and Vlog daily Vlogs and things like
that but would you do you would do like
the fake couple pranks or I would say
some of them were playing cuz it's
entertainment like you know but um I
won't do those things anymore because I
just feel like that's cringy now oh
because they're obviously fake yeah I
mean no no people still watch a lot of
but a lot of those like shout out to my
guy Mystic who was one of those they're
still fake they they were so fake and I
was just like God how many times how
many times can you fake cheat on your
girl before she realizes
it's not real yeah I mean that's just
like that's the but it worked but I
think that was like that was an era of
YouTube yeah like everybody knew like no
one's getting a pencil stuck in their
eye like you know what I'm saying but um
what are you going to do now so no I
that's what I was getting too um so I
decided to go back and I don't know why
I called it a podcast cuz now it's super
being it's like being taken serious so
now I have a responsibility to keep up
but so I decided to take my best friend
her name is dami V
who also does music but um we be having
conversations on the phone and stuff so
I decid to just do do that as like a
chitchat girl but so it turned into a
podcast and it got a lot of views and
people already reached out like trying
to buy or put it on their platform
listen don't sell it yet yeah yeah I I
wasn't going to do that no but what you
should do is do it once a week you got
to be consistent once a week yeah or or
twice a month at the very least so like
I literally this is my I only have my
second um my second one is coming out
tomorrow my second yeah so if you guys
can have like a consistent drop schedule
yeah whether it's twice I would I
wouldn't do anything less than twice a
month but if you could do once a week do
once a week but do it for like a year
and then you that'll be another seven
fig bag for you because I mean there's
other podcasts that are not as uh that
aren't very good that are yeah doing
doing good I mean some money yeah and
then I have the and then I have the
leverage of like bringing on artists
because
you can bring artists on and where you
stay at obviously I'm sure you're
filming there as well there's a lot of
artists that live there so you're going
to be able to have so many guests come
in and then you're probably also going
to be able to get like influencers
you're going to be able to also get like
a side of people who I don't think other
platforms are getting cuz I don't really
think like when I think of like drink
Champs artists go on there but usually
it's like old school hip-hop folks but
they're their guards down cuz they know
Nori but I feel like their artists and
influencers guards will be down with you
because they know you from the music MH
and could have different conversations
with them yeah just realistic yeah do
that run that [__] up that' be dope yeah
that's the way to do YouTu I didn't
expect for that to happen like I I kind
of thought that I was just going to do
one episode but at they were like
waiting on the next one I was like Oh
shoot what did I just do and I called it
a podcast so I feel like podcast is held
to like a higher no no no for sure well
CU now people expect it to be a
consistent thing well if you c a podcast
now people oh yeah I can't believe I did
that to myself but it's okay we going to
keep we going to keep it up I mean I
need another stream income anyway so
yeah no you'll run it up for sure that's
a seven figureure bag for you if you
just stay consistent that's easy for
sure I was going to say um for you like
you've always been somebody like how do
you deal
with um the negatives of being in the
public eye and being in a relationship
because I feel like I you've you've
that's got to be like a hard thing to
kind of like cuz you want to keep your
private life private as much as you can
but you're also you you know what I'm
saying I'm also an artist and I got to
sing about what how I feel and things
like that um
honestly I just tell what I want to tell
and whatever comes
out it comes out because it I don't know
like it just it it happens you can't but
even in that you don't respond like you
just you just deal with it in in your
household but um I mean how do I deal
with it I just like oh I just answered
it I just tell what I want to tell yeah
for sure um has there been someone who
you've met so far because I always say
in the music industry there's tons of
like uh people you know people you work
with uh Associates but not necessarily
friends has there been any artists who
you've bonded some real friendships with
since you've uh been doing the music
thing well well how would you what would
you call a friend and what would you
call an associate well Associates like
yo we work together we H we we a did the
video like you really ain't seeing
somebody or talking to them outside of
like the work like you know but if
there's somebody who you could you know
always call on for relationship advice
or or music advice or someone you just
chat with or like an actual friend you
know the the difference between a work
associate and a friend I don't have an
actual industry friend I don't but I do
have Associates like people that would
check on me from time to time um you
know and outside of music and stuff and
I appreciate it because I mean sometimes
you you can't be friends with people um
you cuz y'all don't have enough time
like I live in Atlanta most of my peers
live in LA so like we not seeing each
other on a daily basis or but I do have
those people that would check on me I
don't really have I can't say I have
friends though like that I'm like this
week yeah they're like yo let's go let's
go get lunch just cuz cuz it's Tuesday
no more I have like more of a actually
yeah I barely have friends so like in
life you no you have a tight ccle very
tight Circle as you should yeah yeah no
that's fair uh on the EP you got LM Eric
Bellinger young boys on here um sh shout
out to uh uh LM who's also an amazing
talent amazing amazing talent she's one
of the ones that check on me she's super
super sweetheart yeah yeah have uh
what's uh what is that a studio session
situation or is that you send this the
record off tour type I sent it to her
because once again I was in Atlanta and
she's in La so but we did tour together
um for the Mary J BL tour we both got to
open up I was there actually I went in
New in Brooklyn did you see did you see
I was there did you see me in the red in
the red fur I was I was I I think I
caught the tail end of your thing me and
Doc wner were acoss stre having DIN and
then we came and you were on yeah that
yeah cuz yeah I forgot yeah that was a
crazy show the Brooklyn show at barlay
yeah that man she brought brought
everybody out bro New York's energy be
crazy like I love New York yo that's
crazy in there rocking yeah no that was
a w again Mary J had like fabulous and
Puff Daddy and uh jiss and I feel like
Fat Joe I don't know it was like all in
New York lot of people mhm what has uh
did like you and Mary developed any sort
of like she give some game while you
guys yes she definitely gave me some
game she gave me some game for sure um
I'm of course every every OG is going to
tell you like keep going no matter what
but she definitely told me
like she told me to take my time and
like wait with
marriage um she been through it yeah
she's been through it public I mean I've
been through it too though I was already
married before she told me that so um
but I am I feel like this time around I
am we have been taking our time I mean
we've been together for almost 6 years
now and people complain cuz you know I
always I always joke around like where
my ring at you know but um in reality
I'm just like whenever he I rather a man
be like
ready like he better hurry up yeah no he
better hurry up but I'm saying though
like you better hurry up no but I'm
saying
that things should be handled before I
feel like um marital counseling is
really good like premarital counseling
before you yeah because like a lot of
times I do see like couples last a long
time outside of marriage and soon as
they get married it [__] things up they
get divorced and I'm a heavy believer in
marriage I still believe in marriage I
still believe it could work is it all
depends on the two people and of course
keeping God like in your marriage you
know what I'm saying
but um yeah it ain't it ain't no
rush but it's not a rush for marriage
but it is like a little rush for like
the Ring The Ring cuz it's like okay at
least if you propose then we know where
we headed we've had conversations about
it like I know that he's going to but
it's like okay six years yeah but you
know sometimes men they want to get
certain things out the way like he wants
to put his clothing line and you know
like they want to
feel like they got a portion of their
life if you guys get married you making
him sign the
prenup um is it going to be the prenup I
we haven't we spoke us about have sign
that thing we spoke about it um I don't
know though I don't I don't know but
probably yeah yeah for sure I just feel
like that it's only fair that if we walk
away from each other it's only fair that
we walk away with what we came with you
know what I'm saying agree 100% yeah but
I feel like I got the kind of
relationship too that like I don't think
he would ever try to you don't think no
I don't think so I hey you don't think I
don't think so I don't think he'll try
to come for my money get the prep that's
all I would say I feel you like it's
smart it is very smart but I'm just
saying the person that I know no I I get
it you know what I'm saying like I get
it but um [__] r that prenup bro a lot
of women don't think though and they do
end up you know but